c'est double trouver une tournée mission
d'abord pour visiter les ateliers nous
avons dans cette région de 15 à plier
donc ça représente une force de ces
camps ce qu'on appelle une double 21e
secteur gentilly yann et c'est un petit
peu un retour aux sources parce qu'il
faut savoir que le rite écossais ancien
et accepté tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
est passée par là martin puisque et et
maurane qui est à l'opa et clark
célébrissime philosophe mais étienne
morin ou n'est que 18ème siècle est
passé par la martinique avant d'arriver
à saint domingue direct stone en
jamaïque pour fonder le rite écossais
ancien et accepté à travers l'amérique
de perfection real à bhl qui a mûri nous
avons compris
raison pour laquelle nous appelons les
délais légaux et malheureusement vous
passez dans ces régions voir le travail
accompli le travail aussi à réaliser et
la structure de hold on me l'a proposé
croyait dans cette région voilà c'est à
dire que nous nouons d'une part pour
rencontrer des frères les soeurs d'un
autre juridiction qui dépend directement
en france ainsi qu'un atelier ont besoin
de d'être soutenus et d'être motivé que
tous les groupes humains et que de se
renouveler
donc nous sommes là pour poursuivre
l'évolution du secteur
jusqu'à présent il y avait un secteur à
très grands secteurs donc guadeloupe
martinique et guyane et nous envisageons
de le fractionner six grands secteurs en
trois secteurs indépendants de façon à
ce qu'ils vivent une copie plus
dynamiques à l'intérieur de la
juridiction et à l'intérieur de
l'assemblée générale et puis d'autres
peurs il faut penser que tourner contre
105 comme la france en tant que suite à
la martinique la guadeloupe la guyane
sont extrêmement importants c'est une
tête de pau
aux amériques de manière générale si on
appelle amérique l'ensemble du corps
antilles car il est pour nous
extrêmement important parce que ça ne
peut utiliser une présence dans ces
états c'est l'exemple que vous citez
tout à l'heure la surface maritime
représente notre mère par rapport à la
france c'est la même configuration des
antilles guyane toutefois la formation
dans les faits c'est à dire que la
maçonnerie a cette particularité le
livre dans l'espace et dans le temps
qu'on faisait référence intégrant à tout
à l'heure
il ya une transmission se fait à partir
de lui et aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend de
faire mousser de communication l'espion
fait et donc le fait de d'accord cet
espace géographique dans lesquels la
france est maintenant ça nous permet de
présenter ce que représente justement
l'un bassono pays en général celle du
grand orient de france en particulier
vous voulez sur la laïcité et la liberté
absolue de conscience écrit sur les
caussadaises fondée sur son caractère
international et sur la spiritualité par
une juridiction c'est celle qui dit le
droit
et c'est une hiérarchie quel est le
regard que vous avez depuis paris sur
ces régions votre mère vous vous pliez
maintenant endémique en venant de bono à
l'origine on parie j'ai un regard
universel sur la maçonnerie gérer normes
universelles sur les sommes dues aux
normes ifrs et sur l'humanité
c'est vraiment ce qu'on cherche à
construire celui qui a en quelque sorte
construit la philosophie que nous
représentons sécurité qui s'appellera on
sait que pratiquement personne ne
connaît mais qui est l équivalent de la
construire qui s'appelait des biens
sociaux nécessairement d'harry potter
à l'époque il a mis trente ou quarante
éditions à l'espace d'un siècle ce qui
est extrêmement important et il a
construit donc une philosophie fondée
sur la république de vercel et sur
mignon du corps et les coeurs et les
esprits de tous les instruments les
primes uniquement des plans d voir des
jaunes
[Musique]
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure du rite
écossais le néophyte non initiés c'est
quoi le rite écossais dans la formation
alors le rite écossais mais c'est
construire ici glissé une construction
humaine qui s'est justement fait à la
suite de ram c'est à la suite de rome
c'est ya eu à peu près 4000 rituel
différents grades qui moulinent
fabriquer et puis nous en avons
sélectionné un certain nombre 33 ans
théorique nous survie lequel nous
travaillons mais qui sont en fait encore
plus anthropologique
ils disent tous ces rituels keith tout
ce qui se passe dans la vie de tous les
hommes
j'ai eut donné un exemple notre totem
parce que aussi une société animiste 1/4
et 1/2 telle série depuis ses fans et
les globicéphales il vient la première
phrase qu'on trouve de l'équipe stéphane
cédant trésor et des même temps amy sène
il ya les noms à rennes c'est la guerre
de troie hélène et c'est donc seront
quasiment premier donc s'arrêter pour
l'événement technique anthropologique et
nous avons rassemblé dans un corps
omnium occidentale judéo-chrétien grec
égyptien est également un latin nous
avons rassemblé plus de 20 à travers une
spécificité en ce qui nous concerne
c'est que nous avons introduit dans la
maçonnerie cénomanien qui essaient de
nous introduire la chevalerie et une
somme en quelque sorte et liquides de
leurs biens nous ne sommes pas des
chevaliers ne sont pas dit one sommes
des êtres humains qui cherchons à
exploiter au maximum ces règles de vie
représentée par